it's gonna explode
so yeah
hi i'm alex and today i'm joined by a
very special guest my girlfriend hi i'm
zoya and today we're gonna be swapping
some of our favorite snacks i actually
brought some of my favorite snacks from
my childhood i also brought snacks from
my childhood but they kind of carried
over into adulthood as well so after
each round we'll decide if we want to
keep our snacks or swap them well let's
get snacking here we are with snack
number one are you ready are you ready i
guess all right
this is called an it's it and it is a
legend of san francisco i'm from
northern california it was made in 1928
and it's just like a staple of san
francisco history what did you bring
mine was probably around before 1928
because it's dried mulberries persians
are a huge fan of dried fruit but
nothing is as common as dried mulberries
and we call them tooth
that's so cute let's start with mine
since it's ice cream so it might melt i
think you're really gonna like this
because it's actually two oatmeal
cookies i do like oatmeal cookies
sandwich with ice cream in the middle
and then dipped in chocolate okay cheers
it's a little hard that's it
is it honestly it's something
okay i feel like i remember them being
better than this back in the 1928
probably was it in 1928.
but like as a kid this was so delicious
it was it now it's is it
very cute good job san francisco
nineteen yeah time for the toot but we
usually eat them with tea cheers too
it's kind of like a raisin
i don't love raisins it's not really
like a raisin maybe you could put the
mulberries in your sandwich that would
help it be
edible it's good they're good would i
keep my snack or swab it for years it's
it
was okay but i think i'd rather have the
mulberries just because these would just
take a freezer space in my house i would
keep my own just because there's very
limited freezer space so if it's gonna
be an ice cream it's gotta be like the
best on to the next round let's see what
we're snacking on next whoa
both drinks like capri sun of course
it's capricious flavor the beverage of
our childhood look at this pouch
strawberry kiwi is the one we have these
were so iconic had them after every
soccer game before every soccer who what
kind of parenting style is that do you
think it'd be a good mixer
wow i have not thought about that maybe
punch a hole empty some of it out pour
in some happy juice seal it back juice
this would be a great mixer so i brought
something that i don't want to mix with
alcohol at all this is called dual it's
a persian yogurt soda usually you drink
it with meals or sometimes by itself as
i say this out loud i realize maybe it
sounds a little different but it is
liquefied yogurt and this one in
particular is a mint flavor as well
and then it's carbonated i'm done that
sounds kind of good interesting way
different than a capri sun all right
let's swap sometimes the very bottom the
yogurt will kind of collect so you want
to give it like a good shake before you
open it
it's carbonated it's going to explode
soya
ah it smells like
yogurt
really salty i could see it being really
refreshing yogurt a little bit sweet and
i even like the mint but like it is so
salty that it's a little hard yeah this
one's pretty salty salty i actually
don't know when last time i had capri
sun was there you go look at that
oh my god that is exactly like i
remember it is so sweet oh my god maybe
we should mix the two
no
it's clear
it is clear look at that it's bubbling
up maybe this is like a reaction like
mentos and coke
no it seemed like a terrible idea but i
want you to go through with it so i
could see what happened are you going to
try it absolutely not
actually i don't want either of these
slimes i'm going to swap them both if i
had to pick one i'd keep the dual
because at least it's interesting but
maybe just like a different
flavor well let's see what's next as i
clean this up all right it's time for
snack number three ready set go snacks
i'm assuming you've had swedish fish
before i think once what yeah i love
swedish fish they're just like kind of
like sweet fruity sour-ish
red is the best flavor so they sell them
in packs of red okay i brought a small
piece of lavo shack which is persian
fruit leather this one is pomegranate
flavor i did you a favor and brought you
a kind of bite-sized piece traditionally
it comes on this long like sheet
basically wedged between plastic and you
have to kind of peel the plastic like a
fruit roll lift yes but those are
designed for the plastic to come off
whereas lava plastic just like doesn't
come off so you will inevitably eat some
of the plastic oh my god i remember
swedish fish as multiple colors i don't
remember them being are you serious
guys i swear please let me know comment
below if you guys remember that swedish
fish word
multicolored it smells like soap oh my
god
they're so good
i love the texture of them
like like
not as hard as a gummy bear
you like these yeah oh you don't like
them no it kind of has a licorice taste
i'm not getting that all right let's try
yours because i have a feeling you're
complaining about this getting stuck in
your teeth i have a feeling that this is
going to get stuck in my teeth it will
get stuck in your teeth
why is everything so salty
very sour i don't hate it i like it i
would say it tastes more natural than
this now like trying this it tastes a
little bit like chemically honestly it
might be good to combine them do it i'm
gonna try it too mmm that is good that's
delicious it's really good we've
completely changed the frame of this
video into just combining snacks
together and see if they work all you
have to do is take your little swedish
fish put some lava shock on there
you got yourself a great snack i guess
this means we'll take both we'll keep
and we'll swap we are ready for our
final snack are you ready i think so
zoya have you had these before york
peppermint patties i don't think i've
ever had these are like a love hate for
me definitely a ton of nostalgia i feel
like i would eat these at my
grandparents house they hold a lot of
memories i brought gas so you brought a
toot and a gas gas has been around for a
long time and it's a very traditional
persian snack it's a nougat with
pistachios inside that sounds good to me
i think you really like this one yeah
all right let me break this puppy open
cheers
oh it's like toothpaste literally tastes
like toothpaste and chocolate my
favorite combination this is
this is odd i do like mint and i like
mint chocolate but this ain't it this
isn't
it okay let me try yours i'm excited for
this one my mouth is overpowered by mint
flavor it looks like a marshmallow
that's yummy chewy
soft
not too sweet the nuts are a nice touch
am i getting like a little bit of rose
water you might it's a classic persian
thing huh rose weather and everything
yeah you had me at gaz you had guys
i'm definitely swapping my york for the
guys i'm gonna keep my guys as much as i
loved the york and there you have it
zoya thank you so much for bringing some
really delicious snacks you're welcome
thank you for bringing
snacks so maybe we'll do this again
maybe not until next time if you want a
real snack follow me on instagram
naturetragen and if you want an even
better snack you can follow me at zoya
roya bye
[Music]
you